KATHARINE NG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Katharine Ng.
I'm on the Authors@Google Team
at Google Los Angeles.
It's my pleasure today to
welcome Amy Stewart to our
Authors@Google series.
Amy is the award winning author
of six books on the
perils and pleasures of the
natural world, including my
favorites, "Wicked Bugs" and
"Wicked Plants." Today, Amy
will talk to us about her new
book, "The Drunken Botanist,"
which is packed with fun facts,
anecdotes, growing
tips, and 50 boozy drink recipes
that explores every
conceivable plant that's
transformed into alcohol.
Amy will also guide us through
a tasting of four types of
spirits made from the strange
and wonderful agave, which
grows abundantly
in Los Angeles.
So please join me in welcoming
Amy Stewart.
[APPLAUSE]
AMY STEWART: Thank you.
And thanks so much for being
here, and for having me.
You must hear this from every
writer who comes here, but
there is absolutely no way I
could do my job or could have
written this book--
accurately at least--
without Google.
So thank you for everything
that you do.
Before I get started, a lot of
you are eating lunch, and
probably don't want to taste
until you're finished eating.
But just in case some of you
can't wait, I think it's cruel
and unusual punishment to put
a flight of spirits in front
of people and not let
them taste them.
So before we even really get
going, I want to tell you what
they are in the order.
So that anyone who's eager to
get going right this second
can move right along.
The pink cup would be number
one, if you want to arrange
these for yourself.
And that's a blanco.
That's why we're starting
with that.
And that is this lovely
Bacanora.
And I'll explain what Bacanora
is, and how it differs from
the other agave spirits.
Anyway, this is number one.
It's a blanco.
So it's unaged.
And then I really debated about
the sequence after this.
But I think this is what
we're going to go with.
The blue one would
be number two.
And the blue one is this amazing
Del Maguey mezcal.
This is their Tobala, which
is a cult classics.
You should be very excited to
be able to taste the Tobala,
because it's highly
sought after.
So let's do that one
for number two.
And then your green
cup has the sotol.
So this is sotol.
And it comes from a
different plant.
It comes from a different
region.
We'll talk more about it.
But this is a repozado.
It's been aged a little.
That's why we're putting
it a little later.
That's green, is number three.
And the number four, which
is practically
dessert, it's so good.
This amazing Don Julio tequila,
it's an anejo.
It's been aged even longer.
And it has all this wonderful
caramel sweetness from the
wood that is just to die for.
That's in the orange cup.
And that would be
the number four.
We will talk more about them
when we get near the end here.
Let me start out a little bit
by just saying, first, how I
got interested in doing this.
It actually started over
a bottle of gin,
not a bottle of tequila.
Like many great ideas,
it was born in a bar.
I was sitting with a friend of
mine who is actually an agave
expert in Tucson.
And he had this bottle of gin.
And he said, I've never really
gotten into gin.
I don't get it.
And I said, how can you be
interested in plants, and not
be excited about gin?
It's just so interesting
how many different
botanicals are in it.
There's not only the grains that
make up the base spirit.
Because all gin is really
just flavored vodka.
If you're a gin drinker and
you think you don't drink
vodka I have bad news for you.
You've been drinking vodka
all this time.
But it's flavored with juniper
berries, and other spices,
other plant material
that makes it gin.
So there's all these
plants in here--
obviously the juniper.
Cardamom's often there.
There's almost always citrus
peel, because the citrus
amplifies some of the
other flavors.
So I'm talking with my friend.
And I said, there's nothing
but plants in this bottle.
And we're sitting at the bar.
And I start waving
my hands around.
And I'm like, come to think of
it, all of these things are
nothing but plants.
There's barley.
And there's agave.
There's sugar cane.
And there's grapes.
And there's wheat.
Everything behind the
bar is a plant.
Don't you find that
just amazing?
Somebody should write
a book about that.
And he goes, maybe you
ought to write a book
about it and shut up.
I wish I could say that
I wrote it down
on a cocktail napkin.
But probably it was
an index card.
As a writer, I usually have
index cards with me.
But fortunately I could read my
handwriting the next morning.
So I knew I was doing for
the next few years.
That was the general idea.
And what I set out to do was
really go plant by plant, and
look at all the things that we
turn into alcohol, starting
with things like-- let me
see what I've got here.
I've got some of the grains.
Obviously agave, which we're
going to talk more about.
And sugar cane, and corn,
and the roots--
that's gentian root.
Violets are used.
All sorts of tree bark,
like cinnamon.
Potatoes for vodka.
All the fruits, there's nuts,
and spices, and seeds.
Juniper, fruit like apples.
There's this vast cornucopia
of plants that have been
fermented and distilled
around the world,
and made into alcohol.
So now when I go into a
liquor store I don't
really see this anymore.
I see this.
And that's really what
I'm getting at.
The way I wanted to do this
was to talk to botanists.
For every plant there's a
botanist somewhere that has
devoted her life or his life
to the study of it.
And very often, I was able to
talk to people doing really
interesting work with the
genetics of these plants and
their history, their
applications in medicine, the
chemistry behind them.
I talked a lot of people in
agriculture who are out
figuring out new varieties
that make better alcohol.
And then, of course,
distillers.
Probably the most grueling part
of the research for this
book was having to go around to
distilleries and taste and
talk to the people actually
making this stuff.
I wrote a book on venomous
insects.
And I got no volunteers
to help with the
research for that book.
And with this one, everybody
wanted to come along and carry
my suitcase, and help.
That was a lot of fun.
And of course all this traveling
around and visiting
distilleries and buying bottles
of stuff to taste so
that I could decide whether to
include it in the book or not,
that's all research.
It's all business expenses.
So it's been a fun few years.
The way I decided to approach
it was to start with the
plants that are actually
fermented and distilled to
make into alcohol.
And that's what we're
going to talk about
today with the agave.
But there are at least a dozen
plants widely used around the
world to actually
produce alcohol.
And then others that are added
as flavorings in the middle of
the process at the distillery,
like hops for beer, or like
Juniper for gin.
And then at the end of the
process there's all these
plants that you might grow
yourself, or buy at the
farmer's market or whatever, to
mix and muddle and infuse
and make it into drinks.
That's the journey that
the drinks take.
And I decided that would be the
journey that I would take,
as well, with all of this.
Let me start by just a quick
disclaimer, a quick venture
into very complex botanical
science, which is this.
This is what plants are doing.
They're taking sunlight, carbon
dioxide, and water.
And they're doing two things.
They're producing oxygen.
And they're producing glucose.
The part of it we're interested
in is, of course,
the glucose.
They take the sugar.
And they store it in all kinds
of interesting ways that make
for a great drink.
Obviously they put it into
fruit, in the case of wine.
And why is the plant
doing that?
It's probably doing that as
a bribe, so that a bird or
someone will want to eat it, and
help move the seed around.
Sometimes they're storing
it in the roots,
like potatoes do.
They put the sugar in the
tubers, because that's where
the next generation of potatoes
will come from.
In the case of sugar cane, they
store it in the stalk.
And every length of sugar cane,
every node in a stalk of
sugar cane has root tissue
and leaf tissue in it.
So you can take a cut piece
of sugar cane and
put it in the ground.
And there's enough sucrose
in the stalk to support
life for the plant.
And it'll root, and put
up leaves if the
conditions are right.
And then of course grains
are nothing but seeds.
Plants take sugar and
turn it into starch,
and put it into grains.
So that when the little seedling
starts to emerge, it
has something to eat.
Because it's not yet big enough
to make its own food.
In the case of grains, it's
a little bit unusual.
I'll just explain quickly
what happens.
When it gets wet, when a seed
gets wet, little enzymes go to
work in the seed, breaking the
starch back into sugar.
And that's called malting
in the booze world.
So when you hear about malted
barley, that's what it means.
It means they've gotten it
wet to force it to start
terminating, just like this.
And that's how malted
barley begins.
It just so happens that barley
has so many of those enzymes
that break starch into sugar
that barley is used in
everything.
It's used a lot of beers, and a
lot of whiskeys and vodkas.
Because once it's done
converting its own starch to
sugar, it will go to work on
corn, and wheat, and rye, and
whatever else is in the mash.
So that's why you always see
malted barley in everything.
It's unusually good at doing
that little trick.
A little bit of chemistry
as well.
And that is this.
Sorry for all the complicated
scientific diagrams.
But what's happening here when
we make alcohol is that we
take sugar.
And we feed it to yeast.
And yeast eat the sugar, and
excrete two waste products--
carbon dioxide and alcohol.
So that's where the
bubbles come from.
And that's where the
booze comes from.
It's a little more complicated
than that.
But pretty much this is how we
take plant sugar and make it
into booze.
And the yeast that we use
has been domesticated.
It's probably the oldest
domesticated
creature on the planet.
We domesticated it long before
we domesticated any
other kind of animal.
Because making drinks was a
high priority early on.
It's not always as simple,
though, as just
feeding sugar to yeast.
A grape is not just
a sugar cube.
There's a lot of other complex
molecules in there.
So there's other things going
on in that process.
And agave is particularly
weird.
And we'll walk through
the process.
But with agave, where's
the sugar?
The heart of the agave that
is used to ferment to make
tequila mezcal, the sugar is
not immediately apparent.
This mash tub has a lot
going on in it.
But these are slow-roasted,
caramelized sugars that will
then be fermented.
Once it's fermented,
it gets distilled.
You just heat it up.
And the steam rises.
And it coils and condenses.
And you get alcohol.
That's the very basic process
for most booze, agave being a
little different.
And that's what we'll
do today.
But the stills can be anything
from a very simple thing like
I just showed you
a picture of.
These are a little more
complex and high tech.
This is the Saint George
distillery in Alameda, and
obviously a little bit
more complicated
equipment to make vodka.
But at its heart you're
just boiling it and
extracting the alcohol.
When you do that, you can
distill to whatever proof you
would like.
And the clear neutral spirits
are often distilled to a very
high proof and then
watered back down.
So vodka might be sold
as 40% alcohol.
But it would have been distilled
to 80%, maybe 90%,
and then watered back down.
Whiskeys and some of these
agave spirits never get
distilled quite that high.
And that's where a lot of
the flavor comes from.
Just the distillation process
alone affects the taste.
I don't expect you
to memorize this.
But I just put it up
here to show you a
complex process it is.
A lot of other stuff comes
out of the still.
The first stuff to come out has
the lowest boiling point.
So it lifts out first.
And it's nasty.
It's like nail polish remover.
You do not want to drink it.
Those are what distillers
call the heads.
And that gets cut out
and thrown away.
And then what they call the
heart is just ethyl alcohol.
That's the good stuff.
That's what we drink.
And then at the end, the
things with the highest
boiling point lift out last.
And they're also pretty nasty,
and not things you
really want to drink.
A whiskey maker leaves a little
of them in for flavor.
Because they do taste
kind of good.
But you can't drink
very much of it.
It would be very toxic.
So the tails are also cut
out and not used.
That's just the very basic
overview of how the process
works, in general,
for everything.
I also want to mention, in case
you're wondering-- if
you're sitting here right now
thinking, wait a minute, if
all that stuff is present in
the mash, and as you're
distilling it you're throwing
out the really toxic stuff,
what about beer and wine?
Wouldn't all that stuff
be in there, then?
And the answer is,
yeah, it is.
But in such small quantities
that you're not going to drink
enough to get sick.
Well, you could drink
But please don't.
It's just there's so much
else in the bottle.
There's water.
And there's a lot of other
things going on.
But the is yes, to a certain
extent that stuff is in there.
And winemakers and beer makers
very carefully control their
process to get the product they
want, and not have a lot
of other, nasty, volatile
components in there that they
don't like.
That's part of the mastery of
beer making and winemaking, is
doing that well.
Let's get straight
to the agave.
It has an amazing
history, really.
We know this because of cave
paintings like these, and also
a certain amount
of literature.
When Europeans arrived,
we burned--
we arrived in Latin America,
we burned their books.
They had written science.
They had written literature.
They had a written history.
And a lot of those books, we
took them and we burned to
them, as part of our needing
to take over their culture.
So there's not much
the survives.
But there are some--
these are called codices, these
codex, you'll see them.
They're still in libraries.
That survives.
Cave paintings survive.
And archaeological evidence
survives.
So we know that they were making
alcohol with agave
prior to the Europeans'
arrival.
Mostly they were
making pulque.
I'll show you what that looks
like in a minute.
But the other thing we have,
the other bit of
archaeological evidence
we have--
most of you are more or
less finished eating.
I think you'll be able to
get through this OK.
There's this amazing
archaeologist who has done
analysis of coprolites, which
are basically fossilized feces
found at archaeological sites.
I didn't know if you knew that
was a job, but that's a job.
In case any of you are looking
to make a career
move, that's an option.
And what he actually figured out
is that he could rehydrate
them and tell by the smell how
much pulque or agave--
I'm sorry.
That's as gross as it's
going to get.
You'll be OK.
But he was able to detect high
levels of pulque, or this
fermented agave drink, just
by doing that analysis.
There's also drawings that
show people making and
drinking this stuff.
And certainly by the time the
Europeans arrived, once the
Europeans got here, they
more thoroughly
documented the process.
So to make pulque--
some of you guys have surely had
pulque, because we're here
in Southern California.
You've been to Mexico.
You know what the stuff is.
It is fermented from
the agave sap.
So it's a totally different
process from how these spirits
are made, and different species
of agave are used.
But basically the really simple
version is that as this
agave plant is getting ready
to put up its central
flowering stalk, it is cut and
scraped so that sap starts to
flow from the center
of the agave plant.
And you draw off that
sap, and ferment it.
At the time, of course,
it was just
fermented with wild yeast.
And you make this mildly
alcoholic drink that doesn't
stay good for very long.
You cannot go by pulque in the
grocery store in a can.
It's an actively fermenting
thing.
And it goes south after
a few days.
It starts to get really sour.
It's a very short lived thing.
But they were definitely
making pulque
when Europeans arrived.
So that was a very old
tradition, and an ancient use
of the plant.
Just some other photos, just so
you can get a sense of the
enormity of these plants, and
the way this process looked.
What they're doing is they're
extracting the sap by using,
in this case, a gourd
to siphon it off.
It's a really interesting
process.
Now agave sap is sort of
hard to work with.
So they naturally ferment it.
But they don't distill it.
The thing is that some of these
sugars are just less
fermentable than others.
There's a lot of different
bacteria and biologically
active creatures living
on and in the agave.
And the sugar content
is just a lower.
So you cannot really
distill that stuff.
You'd get a lot of very
nasty, off flavors.
And it would not work well.
So that is not what is distilled
to make tequila, and
other spirits.
It goes through a very
short phase.
It starts out being kind
of like yogurt.
It gets to where it's maybe
3% to 7% alcohol.
It goes through a regular
alcoholic fermentation.
And then it goes south really
quickly, and starts to produce
some pretty nasty off flavors,
vinegar type flavors.
And sometimes they'll do a
second fermentation that helps
the process.
But basically it's quick,
and then it's over.
Now the spirits that we're going
to talk about are made
using a completely different
process, and completely
different species of agave.
The first step is to cut out the
heart of the agave, which
looks like an artichoke heart
if you think about it.
The plant is killed
for this purpose.
You can't harvest it, and keep
the plant in the ground.
The whole plant is harvested.
And you chop away, and
get this heart.
You can see what they
look like here.
The old way of doing this was
to roast them slowly in an
underground pit for
several days.
There are more high tech
ways of doing it today.
But originally they would have
been very slowly roasted.
Sometimes they're in above
ground ovens like this.
And modern tequila makers are
often doing them in just giant
autoclaves.
And they're steaming them
instead of doing the slow
underground roasting process.
But that's really
the first step.
Then they're crushed.
And back in the day they would
have been crushed like this,
with one of these
donkey wheels.
This is something that's been
done in Europe forever.
You'll see this exact same
process for apple cider, and
other things in Europe.
And this would be the old
process for crushing the
agave, and getting this fibrous
mix that's going to
then be fermented.
There's one from Europe.
So you can see they're
totally the same.
Now why do have to roast them?
The reason is that you need
this process to happen.
We talked about breaking
starch into sugars.
It's even more complicated
with agave.
So there's a caramelization
process that happens, where
you get the sugars in the
presence of exactly the right
he level, and they will
start to break down.
And you will get this beautiful
brown color.
And you'll get those nutty
flavors, and flavors that will
remind you of rum, that
warm rum flavor.
So that's what happens when
you caramelize something.
And that's part of the process
with agave hearts.
The other thing is that you get
this other reaction, the
Maillard reaction, which is what
happens when sugars and
amino acids come together
in the presence of heat.
A good example of this would
be toast, roasted coffee,
roasted potatoes.
And when you caramelize
onions, actually both
reactions are happening
at the same time.
Caramelization is happening,
because there are sugars in
onions, but you're also getting
this Maillard reaction
happening as well.
Both of those things contribute
to this warm,
brown, rich, toasty, roasted
kind of flavor.
Now once it's been roasted,
it's time to ferment it.
And sometimes, particularly with
modern tequila, they're
just taking this wash off
of the crushed stuff.
And they're fermenting that, in
which case it's a big tub
of basically a liquid
that gets fermented.
But with some of these more
traditional spirits that we're
going to taste today, the fibers
are still in the mash
tub for the fermentation
process.
And that definitely changes the
flavor, and is why they
taste so different
from tequila.
It's wonderful stuff.
I wish I could have had some
here today for you to taste.
I've tasted just the roasted
agave heart.
And it's like a cross
between an artichoke
heart and beef jerky.
It's this wonderful meaty,
fantastic flavor.
Now the still can
be very simple.
And certainly the earliest
stills that we know about look
not too different from this,
just a big thing where you
boil the stuff.
And it rises up into some
sort of condensing pipe.
Sometimes it goes through
water to help with the
cooling, and into
another vessel.
It can be very simple
like that.
There's an interesting bit
of controversy among
archaeologists right now,
about when exactly this
process started.
Because we know when the
Europeans got here they were
totally making tequila, right
when they first arrived,
pretty much.
But the natives, the locals,
were already
roasting agave hearts.
They were doing this
whole process.
And there's a little bit of
archaeological evidence to
suggest that they were already
distilling, before the
Europeans got here.
So this is a very unsettled
question right now.
But you do wonder, why would
they go to all the trouble to
do the whole process, and
not just finish it.
Because it doesn't look like
they were just using it as a
food source.
It looks like it was
more for alcohol.
So I'll be interested to see
where that issue goes.
Obviously, like I showed you
before, sometimes they're
using much more modern
looking stills.
So it really depends on the
producer, what kind of still
they use, what sort of flavor
they want to get.
And I just wanted to mention,
I love this quote from
"Scientific American,"
from 1897, which I
found thanks to Google.
Appreciate that.
Anyway, "mezcal is described as
tasting like a mixture of
gasoline, gin, and
electricity.
Tequila is even worse, and said
to incite murder, riot,
and revolution," which
I just think is a
wonderful way to describe.
Certainly in 1897 it was
not the fine spirits
that we have today.
It took while for this industry
to evolve and mature.
And it's really even been in
only the last 10 or 20 years
that we've had these really fine
artisanal spirits coming
out of Mexico.
I know this is a bit
hard to read.
It's actually a page
from the book.
But I did want to point out what
we have, and what we're
dealing with here.
The first definition that you
ought to know is that just
because it says tequila on the
label doesn't mean it can't be
a mixture of tequila
and basically
just a neutral spirit.
So you want to look for 100%
agave on the label.
So you know it's not mixed
with anything.
And in general the definition,
so unaged is called silver or
blanco or plata.
They all mean the same thing.
In the case of tequila, you
can get a gold, which is
called joven or oro, which is
with caramel color added, and
maybe some other extracts,
but not aged.
So gold is not aged.
And in the aged, of course,
is the repozado.
And it's at least two months.
And the extra aged anejo has
to be at least a year.
And there is a category called
ultra aged, extra anejo, which
is at least three years.
And most of these spirits
generally follow those
definitions, with some
variations between them.
A couple other things about
what can and can't be in
there, there is no worm
in tequila, ever.
It is something that by
law you cannot add.
The definition of mezcal
allows them to add it.
What it is the larva of a couple
of different pests of
the agave plant, the agave snout
weevil, as an example.
And the good mezcal makers hate
it, that this is even
permitted, and feel that it
reflects badly on all of them.
Obviously it does nothing
to the flavor.
It's just a dumb gimmick.
Ignore it.
Paid no attention to the worm.
There have been some studies
that show that a bit of
worminess is extracted when you
drop it into a solvent.
So if you are drinking a mezcal
with the worm in it,
I'd like to assure that
a little warm DNA is
present in every sip.
So have fun with that.
That's important to you.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What's the D.O.?
AMY STEWART: The D.O. is the
geographic area of origin.
Dominacion de Origen, is
what it is in Spanish.
So just like champagne there's
a region in France, and if
you're going to call it
champagne it has to come from
that region, for these spirits
they all have regional
definitions.
I think I've got a map here.
I should be able to show
you some of that.
These are the drinks.
So let's talk about them.
The pictures I have are not
exactly what we're drinking.
But I actually managed
to get pretty close.
And these are in the wrong
order for our tasting.
Because we decided on the order
of the tasting like half
an hour ago.
And I did this last week.
Taste them.
If you haven't started
tasting yet--
are you ready?
Have you guys been waiting?
Or have you been drinking?
You've been waiting?
Let's talk about let's
talk about them for
the purposes of drinking.
And then I will walk
through them.
So the pink is the cielo rojo.
So if you haven't tasted it yet,
you have my permission.
This is a blanco.
And mostly I went in this order
just because of whether
or not it's aged.
So that is this bottle.
This is the Bacanora.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: They ran out of
it before I came here,
so I have an empty.
Can I?
AMY STEWART: You
want a refill?
AUDIENCE: They didn't
have them, so I
just made my own plate.
AMY STEWART: You can totally
just fill up.
We used a measuring cup for
everyone else so that you'd
only get a half an ounce.
I know.
I can trust you, right?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AMY STEWART: Sure.
Wow.
You're watching him.
There's adult supervision
taking place.
OK, so the pink one
is the cielo rojo.
What do you guys think?
By the way, the guidance when
you're tasting spirits is, if
you're going to sniff, do with
your mouth open, not your
mouth closed.
To be honest, I don't know
if it makes a difference.
But that's a thing.
What do you think?
What do you taste?
AUDIENCE: Smoky.
AMY STEWART: Still pretty smoky,
because it's roasted,
unlike some of the tequilas,
which aren't roasted as much.
You still get the smoke
from the roasted.
What else, anything?
Floral, a little bit of
maybe some bright
happy floral notes.
Worcestershire sauce,
that's interesting.
What is that, the heat
or the smokiness?
Feel free to drink some
water in between.
You ready to move on?
You're good?
You guys, you're so quiet
and well behaved.
The blue is the Del
Maguey mezcal.
And these guys are
unbelievable.
They're doing these small
village mezcals.
And so every one is different.
It's very specific
to the village.
You go into some of
these villages.
They're really making
it the same way
they have since forever.
They're doing them
in little huts.
They're often sleeping there,
right next to the still.
There's this whole thing about
how nobody can come in who's
got on any kind of perfume,
soap, or lotion, or
anything like that.
Because they don't even
want that getting in
the way of the flavor.
And this Tobala, I think I'll
have a picture of the Tobala
in a minute.
So this refers to the
plant that's used.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Smells like cheese.
AUDIENCE: Smells
very caramelly.
AUDIENCE: Smells like grappa.
AMY STEWART: Like
grappa, sweet.
Really complex and
interesting.
And I will just tell you that
everything they make is
different from everything
else.
So when you've had one
Del Maguey, you have
not had them all.
They're all really rare
and wonderful.
This one is very highly
sought after.
This is something that people
are very into, and always very
happy to get to taste
when they can.
Any other comments on
the Del Maguey?
Maguey, by the way,
means agave.
So the third one we're going to
do, we're getting into the
aged stuff.
And some serious yumminess
happening.
This is the sotol.
And in just a second we'll
show you the slides.
And I'll show you the difference
in the plants and
the regions with the sotol.
It, by the way, is organic.
So this is a repozado.
So it's been aged
a little bit.
What do you think?
More caramel?
More yummy woodsy?
AUDIENCE: Smoother.
AMY STEWART: Smoothness, yeah
the wood definitely, the
process of the spirit going in
and out of the wood acts as
its own filtration.
So definitely smooths it out.
AUDIENCE: Where does that
color come from?
AMY STEWART: From the wood.
The color comes from the wood.
Definitely comes out of the
still clear, but then gets a
little color from the wood.
You guys doing all right?
You have water?
You going to be all right?
AUDIENCE: Getting
warm in here.
AMY STEWART: Getting warm.
OK, and then the last one
is the Don Julio.
This is the anejo.
And this one is so yummy.
This is just like dessert.
I love all the sweetness
and the caramel
and the wood in this.
That's the Don Julio
anejo tequila.
What do you think?
Yeah, pretty nice.
I know.
Butterscotch.
Do not put that in a
Margarita, please.
Do not pollute this with
lime juice or salt.
No, no, no.
Tequila can only be made
with agave tequilana.
Weber Blue.
Weber Blue is the name of
the specific cultivar.
So all plants have
a species name.
But within that there can be a
lot of different cultivars
that usually refer to physical
characteristics, other than
the flower the reproductive
organs.
And so agave tequilana is the
only plant they can use if
they're going to call
it tequila.
And of course it can only
be made in a region
right around Jalisco.
And there are some issues with
the plants themselves.
There's not a lot of
genetic diversity.
It's kind of a monoculture,
like some grape growing
regions get to be sort
of a monoculture.
So there's concerns about the
health of the plants, and the
fact that it hasn't
been allowed to
interbreed and get stronger.
Because they don't need to
flower to make tequila.
So they don't really get to
flower, and get pollinated,
and mate, and have children.
Unless somebody does that
deliberately, it's not part of
the process, otherwise.
AUDIENCE: So where do they
get the new plants from?
AMY STEWART: They clone them.
They get the new plants
through cloning.
Now the mezcal we tasted.
There's a list of particular
different agaves that can be
used to make mezcal,
in particular.
And the Tobala is on my
list, Agave potatorum.
Maybe I did get a picture
of the Tobala.
I think that is the Tobala.
Certain species, and it has to
be made around Oaxaca and
particular other designated
regions, in order for you to
be able to call it mezcal.
Typically always made with the
roasting, none of this
steaming in big network
containers, like they might do
with tequila.
The sotol, very different
plant.
Not even an agave.
So that was this one.
This is what's in
your green cup.
It's a plant called the desert
spoon, also called the sotol,
and made around Chihuaua
and Durango.
I'll show you a map in a second,
so you can visualize
all this stuff.
And so this is another spirit
that's just starting to come
in to its own, and really get
some recognition, and get a
legal definition.
So they have some protection
of what can be called sotol
and what can't.
But very different plant,
not even an agave.
And then finally, Bacanora,
made in Sonora.
That was actually what
we started with.
We started with a nice
blanco Bacanora.
And it's only one particular
species of agave as well.
It's made from Agave
angustifolia.
Different species, and again,
different region.
Otherwise, the processes are
more or less the same.
Now there's one that we didn't
get to try, which is Raicilla.
And it's harder to
find in the US.
But if you're in Puerto
Vallarta, and you want to look
around in that area, Raicilla is
starting to be better known
in that region.
And again, there's only a few
species of agave that can be
used to produce Raicilla.
So that's the other agave spirit
that's up and coming in
this world.
Now if you're not in Mexico, if
you're somewhere else, and
you want to make tequila,
you can.
But you can't call it that.
You can call it 100%
agave spirit, or
something like that.
So, for instance, Saint George
distillery up in Alameda makes
this lovely stuff, Agua Azul,
which is made from an agave.
I'm not sure if they
use tequilana.
I think they probably do.
And it's very nice.
But it's American made.
So they can't call it any
of those other names.
They just have to say agave
spirit, and hope people know
what that means.
Throughout the world,
that's the same.
There's some coming
out of South
Africa, places like that.
Same deal.
They just can't use these
protected words.
This map will give you
some idea of where
this stuff is happening.
The tequila is the
blue region.
That should look familiar to
you, right around Jalisco.
And then the mezcal in green
is further to the south.
But there's other regions,
as you can see, that
can use it as well.
Bacanora up there to the north,
very specific area.
The Raicilla is not
on this map.
It's near Puerto Vallarta.
But they're not quite
as established yet.
So I don't have it on the map.
Sotol, the big beige
area up there.
And also Charanda is on here,
which is actually
not agave at all.
It's sugar cane.
But that's the chart
that I had.
There's [INAUDIBLE]
in a tiny little region.
So those are the regional
differences with these spirits.
Now I mentioned that there were
some ecological issues.
The Tequila Interchange Project
is working to raise
awareness about protecting
these plants.
So with the agave tequilana
Weber Blue that's used to make
tequila, there's concerns
about a lack of genetic
diversity, that it's getting
weakened and
more disease prone.
And there needs to be better
breeding programs, and also
less of a monoculture.
With these others, they're
mostly harvesting wild plants.
So there are some issues
with wild harvesting.
And a call for more conservation
put in place.
You will hear some of the makers
of these spirits say
that they have to be harvested
wild, that these plants cannot
be cultivated.
And that's not true.
Most of them are already in
cultivation, and being grown
out in tissue culture labs by
the thousands, and available
for purchase at Home Depot.
They are not uncommon.
They are not free spirits that
can only grow in the wild.
You could plant them in
a row, and farm them.
So there's a little bit of
mythology about that that
needs to be corrected.
But all the issues that happen
in any kind of agriculture,
with water use and chemical
use, and the health of the
soil, are all issues with these
that are being debated
and talked about right now.
And the Tequila Interchange
Project works on that stuff.
And also protecting
small producers.
There's definitely a big guys
versus small guys conflict
happening in this
world right now.
As the small producers are
trying to make sure that laws
don't get written that
only favor the big
multinational companies.
And if you don't believe
me, you can
go see it for yourself.
Get on the Tequila Train.
There is a tequila train,
believe it or not.
This is something you
can totally go do.
Just Google Tequila Express.
And there it will be.
Board the train.
And they take you around.
So there's this whole tourism
thing you can do.
And perhaps even more fun that
would be to go to Oaxaca.
And you can take mezcal tours.
You could just wait until you
get to town and figure it out.
That would be totally doable.
But if you like to be a little
more organized than that,
you'll find it.
If you just Google Oaxaca
mezcal tours you'll get
several places that run little B
and Bs and will also arrange
tours for you.
So you can get around
and taste.
And of course, right in Oaxaca
there's lots of places to just
taste all this stuff.
So you can totally go see all
this stuff, if you want to.
If this was not enough.
There you go.
We're at the end.
Does anybody have any questions
or comments?
You're all stupefied.
You're stunned into silence?
AUDIENCE: What was
the second one?
AUDIENCE: What's that
one-- chicha?
AMY STEWART: Chicha.
AUDIENCE: So it developed
separately from the whole
agave movement?
AMY STEWART: Chicha is a
homemade beer, usually made
from some kind of grain,
corn, as an example.
There's this real tradition in
Peru, for example, of doing
chicha with corn.
And the interesting thing with
some of these chichas is that
the way you get that process
started of breaking the starch
into sugars that we were talking
about, is that you
chew dried corn.
And the enzymes in your saliva
start that process.
And then you split it into
a communal mash tub.
We'll be bringing in some of
that in just a minute for you
to taste, as a special treat.
So that's usually how
that process goes.
And this stuff is
all very tribal.
It was really just a question
of what was available.
And people were working
with what they had.
And some tribes really travel
to follow fruit, and other
food sources, and made a
different alcohol with it
wherever they went.
What else?
Somebody said something
over here.
AUDIENCE: What was
the second one?
What was the name of
the second bottle?
AMY STEWART: Number two,
this one, blue.
This is Del Maguey.
And this is their Tobala,
which is lovely.
That was the blue one.
Yeah, in the back.
AUDIENCE: I notice with wine,
some people talk about the
quality of the earth
and so on.
And I heard you say, in contrast
when growing agave,
there's ways to cultivate it and
so on where you can do it
in a more industrial way.
Is there any discussion about
what kind of soil that you
need for growing agave as part
of the discussion that you
were describing?
AMY STEWART: The question of
what kind of soil you need to
grow agave is really
important one.
Because this plant does what
it does because of stress.
It's a plant that doesn't
need a lot of water.
It can cope with incredible
drought, incredible stress.
And so to a certain extent,
stressing the plant is really
good for what you're
trying to do.
This is actually true in some
ways with fruits, as well.
They produce more antioxidants
when they're under stress,
things like that.
So the soil definitely matters,
and the conditions.
Not being an agave farmer
myself, I hesitate to say.
But if it does seem and from the
agave experts I've talked
to, that there probably is a
way to cultivate them in a
more farm-like setting.
But still give them some of the
same stressors that they
experience in the wild.
But the question the soil health
overall is a big one.
And there's real concern about
the soil being depleted,
particularly in the case of
tequila and these giant farms.
So soil conservation and keeping
the nutrient mix where
it needs to be in the
soil is a big issue.
And one that needs a lot more
work, still in its infancy.
What else?
AUDIENCE: So you said there's a
very strict guideline as far
as percentage of agave you need
to be classified as a
certain drink.
Who made those regulations?
Who enforces it?
Is it international law?
How does that work?
AMY STEWART: How those rules get
enforced about what gets
called what, originally
everything
was just called mezcal.
That was just a native
word for it.
And then the word tequila
started being used for those
spirits produced
around tequila.
And it eventually got codified
into Mexican law.
And then it's only been just
recently that these other
spirits have been able to come
along and claim their own
geographic designation,
as well.
It's part of federal law.
And enforced that way.
Although as with everything,
there's always some activism
needed to really enforce
it properly.
And I know that these smaller
producers are always watching
labels to look for
infractions.
And then outside of Mexico,
this stuff actually gets
enforce pretty well
by governments
in the United States.
We are, of course, the biggest
buyer of all this stuff.
But also in Europe.
So the TTB here in the US
supports and recognizes these
definitions, and enforces
this labeling on
products sold in the US.
For any product like this that's
made in Mexico, in
order for it to be sold in the
US, they have to make a US
compliant label, and
get label approval.
And then if they want to sell it
in the EU, they have to do
the same thing there.
And the same thing in Canada.
So a producer has to go through
a different label
approval process everywhere.
And in the case of these names
and all this recognition, that
has to be re-looked at every
time they get label approval.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Do they ever actually
make it differently?
Like if you buy it in Mexico,
it would be a little bit
different than the one they
sell here or the one
they sell in Canada?
AMY STEWART: They certainly
can, and do.
For instance, they might want
to bottle it at a different
proof, if there's a proofing
issue with it.
What they're doing there, you
definitely can get different
stuff there than you
can get here.
Yeah, over here?
AUDIENCE: What is the flavor
ranger in the--
AMY STEWART: How wide is the
range of flavors for tequilas
and mezcals as compared--
the flavor range can really
be quite wide.
And you guys have such a good
opportunities to taste, here
in Southern California.
And you will find, if you sit
down and do a very nice flight
of agave spirits at a good bar
here, you will find such a
wide range of very floral--
astonishingly floral flavors--
to the darkest smokiest,
something very close to
scotch, and everything
in between.
It is astonishing, the range.
But you always get
that agave thing.
So in that way, I think
it is like brandies.
Where, while there's a wide
range depending on how it's
aged and the style, you're
always still
getting that same fruit.
You're getting that great
thing underneath.
But I think the styles are
getting even wider now.
And I've seen people
doing liqueurs.
There's going to be more and
more agave based liqueurs.
There's a coffee liqueur.
There's a nice orange liqueur.
You have that agave base.
But they're there playing
with it more now.
This market has finally
just really matured.
And they can start
to branch out.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the yield
on these things?
I can see with corn, you get
so much alcohol for so many
pounds of stuff you put in--
grapes-- it's probably pretty
well known.
Are the plants comparable
as well?
It kind of seems like with a
desert plant, you're going to
get less juice for the amount
of plans that you use.
AMY STEWART: But they are not
only just pressing and
breaking the fiber up.
But there's water in that
fermentation process, as well.
So it's a little bit different
than something like grapes,
where all the liquid is just
coming from the plant.
It's more like with beer, where
you're taking the grains
and water too.
AUDIENCE: More extracted
than just--
AMY STEWART: Right.
And I don't remember.
I should know this.
I don't remember how many pounds
of agave it takes for
one bottle.
That's a very good question.
Quick, somebody, come
on you guys.
You already have the
answer, right?
Somebody looked this up by now.
No?
You're letting me down.
What else?
Anything?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe [INAUDIBLE],
but what's
your next book about?
AMY STEWART: What's the
next book about?
The next book is actually
a closely guarded
secret at the moment.
I'm not telling.
Is that everything?
OK, well thank you
all so much.
This was fun.
[APPLAUSE]